[Musique]
astroturf in faux profils nous avons vu
dans le premier épisode de notre série
que la présidentielle est un moment de
vulnérabilité sur les réseaux sociaux
alors que font les plateformes le groupe
métal anciennement facebook a par
exemple annoncé mi février la création
d'un centre opérationnel virtuel pour la
présidentielle le but est de détecter
les événements suspect pour pouvoir les
contrer mais les utilisateurs restent en
réalité très exposé c'est ce que
constate au quotidien david chavalarias
et son équipe de chercheurs
alors les plateformes disent lutter
elles font des actions très concrètes
souvent elle bat nice des séries de
compte dont elles jugent qu'elles ont
qu'ils ont abusé en fait de la plate
forme soit en démultipliant en utilisant
des robots en diffusant des messages
haineux mais c'est là loin d'être
suffisant et notamment la plupart des
plateformes quasiment toutes en fait on
une politique de fermeture des données
donc pour des personnels de la recherche
milieux académiques et même des
gouvernements c'est très difficile de
voir à quel point en fait elles font
travailler sérieusement par contre ce
que l'on peut voir c'est
qu'effectivement souvent il est fait en
retard et certains compte qu'on a
observée en 2010 16 sont toujours actifs
en 2022
face à l'ampleur du phénomène de
nombreux médias ont créé ces dernières
années des services de fact checking ces
cellules aux premières loges constate
bien que le flux de fausses informations
ne diminue pas au sein de france 24
cette mission est confiée au journaliste
et ses observateurs
si on prend juste les chiffres en 2017
on va laver factcheck 48 intox qui avait
donné lieu donc à 48 articles sur le
site des observateurs l'année dernière
en 2021 on avait checker 191 intox qui
avait donné lieu à 191 article c'est une
progression de 4 fois supérieure à la ja
50 donc ça veut pas dire forcément qu il
ya plus d'un toxiques avant en tout cas
on les surveille davantage et surtout je
dirais que sur tous les sujets va y
avoir des intox associés en images lors
de la précédente élection présidentielle
en 2017 il ya eu notamment une vidéo qui
a été partagée assez tôt au début de la
campagne présidentielle où on voyait
soin de soi disant un migrant qui a
agressé une infirmière dans un hôpital
et ça avait été utilisée par beaucoup de
comptes proche de l'extrême droite
notamment un compte twitter très célèbre
qui s'appelle napoléon et donc pour dire
regardez ces personnes là bénéficient de
la couverture maladie universelle et
vont s'en prendre à nos pauvres
infirmières en fait en faisant une
recherche d'image inversée sur cette
vidéo on trouver très rapidement qu'elle
n'avait absolument rien à voir avec une
situation en france parce qu'elle avait
été prise en 2017 en russie un homme
gorod et il s'agissait d'un homme qui
était totalement saoul qui avait agressé
une infirmière
les jeunes qui s'informent
principalement sur les réseaux sociaux
sont parmi les plus exposées à la
désinformation en ligne l'association
génération numérique intervient dans les
collèges et les lycées pour sensibiliser
les élèves cyril di palma en élu délégué
général il nous en dit plus
ils savent swype et escrocs les utiliser
les réseaux sociaux très facilement en
revanche ils ne connaissent pas toujours
les tenants et les aboutissants et le
rôle des algorithmes le et les moyens de
se prémunir de la fausse information
notamment en vérifiant la qualité ou la
source d'une d'une photo ou d'une vidéo
de regarder des avis qui peuvent être
divergents ou opposées pour se faire
leur propre opinion ils ont une tendance
un peu naïve un peu crédule de croire ce
qui qui arrivent notamment quand ça
vient d'un proche ou d'un proche d'un
proche comment vérifier une information
les utilisateurs peuvent s'appuyer sur
les rédactions de fact checking pour
avoir les bons réflexes leur rôle est
d'avertir quand une fausse information
circule mais aussi d'expliquer comment
et avec quels outils ils ont vérifié
alors cette démarche allait adopter par
des journalistes mais aussi par des
internautes qui colle à bartoli
effectivement c'est quelque chose qui
est de plus en plus prisée également par
n'importe quel citoyen notamment les
citoyens qui font de la vérification
avec des sources ouvertes la
vérification aux int qui utilisent des
outils qui sont librement disponibles
sur les réseaux sociaux qui souvent sont
gratuits pour aller varie vérifier par
exemple lorsqu'une vidéo a été diffusée
sur les réseaux sociaux bien comment on
peut là géolocalisé comment on peut
vérifier que cette vidéo est bien
récente à partir d'outils libres d'accès
par rapport à la météo qu'on voit dans
la vidéo par rapport à des outils de
recherche d'image inversée bien tout ça
c'est quelque chose qui est très
important pour restituer les faits
exacts et montrer ce qui s'est passé
pour ne pas tomber justement dans la
logique de l'opinion et d'éviter de
laisser libre cours à n'importe quelle
propagande ou n'importe quelle tentative
de manipulation si on donnait trois
conseils aux jeunes utilisateurs pour
lutter contre la désinformation en ligne
ce seraient les suivants premièrement
adopté une méthode journalistique de
vérification des sources de croiser les
informations
le deuxième conseil ça serait de
comprendre l'usagé des photos des vidéos
et du langage qui peuvent influencer
voire les manipuler et enfin ça pourrait
de prendre conscience que notre propre
cerveau est un outil formidable mais qui
peut nous induire en erreur à travers ce
qu'on appelle nos biais cognitif et de
raisonnement
notre cerveau peut nous jouer des tours
et des acteurs malveillants savent bien
comment en tirer profit
merci d'avoir suivi notre vidéo jusqu'au
bout et à très bientôt sur france 24